there is much more talent to tap into
than ever before but in most parts of
the world we are screwing it up so we
require too much seniority for too many
different jobs there is too much
credentialism our school feeder systems
rely too much on homework and this
discriminates against rebellious people
and just in general we're too slothful
and bureaucratized when it comes to
choosing talent
tyler cowan welcome to the show happy to
be here
i've just read a blog post from mike
solana at piratewise talking about
population collapse have you read this
one yet
uh no i have not but i i think i've
heard that kind of argument before so
he's got this great uh idea i'm big into
existential risk have been for a long
time and he makes a really interesting
argument about the great filter robin
hansen's thing he says from this
perspective elon's efforts are obvious
attempts to eliminate potential filters
that threaten a blossoming civilization
like runaway climate change nefarious
artificial intelligence or being stuck
on earth during a cataclysmic event but
among our greatest existential threats
population collapse is unique in that it
lacks a noticeable immediate pain for us
to rally against there are no wildfires
or smog-filled skies to capture the
imagination of our journalists or
filmmakers thus inspiring no individual
action it is precisely because of this
attention void that i believe we
encountered the true great filter what
do you think about that
i'm much more optimistic than mike is
we have at least two countries france
and england if you consider that a
country where fertility has returned to
replacement levels now that may or may
not last but i find that very
encouraging that it's possible i think
also we will have new technologies that
lower the costs of raising children
and just theoretically there are gains
from trade
from having more kids now the question
is can people selfishly capture the
gains for more children but i'm
convinced that over time especially if
nation states truly start to shrink
become vulnerable to foreign
exploitation and capture that we will
find ways to get population numbers back
up again so people freaked out about
this in the 1920s
it turned out they were wrong eventually
they'll be wrong again
maybe not in singapore but for the world
as a whole
what do you think has caused that at
least population slow
there are things to do that are more fun
than having kids
and then you have a number of cultures
south korea and italy would be two
examples where the men just don't help
out that much on raising the children so
women think well i would like to have a
child one is enough and they stop it's a
real problem i agree but ultimately we
know the technology unlike with some of
these other problems right the
technology is fun and we will fix it
that's true it's a little bit easier of
a solution
than trying to knock an asteroid of
course to just get people to do what
they've been doing for
all of history
that's correct now you might have the
worry that it will disfavor particular
regions of the world so east asia for
whatever reasons seems to be especially
poor at reboosting fertility it may be
east asian men are not so keen to help
with raising the children
so if you're east asian
arguably you should be quite worried i
mean that's a real concern but again for
the world as a whole
i think we will have enough volatility
and fertility rates that will just
manage to keep billions of people on
this earth each and every year he's good
for better or worse this really lovely
quote where he says uh demography is not
destiny but it's pretty damn close and
you'll have seen these um graphs that
are kind of the shape of a pair or a
triangle and it's got the youngest at
the bottom and the oldest at the top and
it allows you to see
the proportion of how old
a civilization is and what you want is
this shape where there's more young than
there is old and then you get towards
some of the east asian countries and
they start to look a lot like an apple
but obviously what you can see is as
that continues to move up that's going
to be the shape at the top so you're
going to end up with this
inverted triangle shape it's pretty
dangerous
but keep in mind we're likely to fix
alzheimer's and dementia to at least
some degree so old won't be as bad as it
used to be
and uh demography makes me feel good
about being an economist because i don't
have to think my science is the very
worst at predictions
demography is very poor at predicting
turning points right so
it's a note of caution but for me not a
note of deep concern
okay well given the fact that we're
talking about the hopeful
non-implosion of our population talent
which is the subject of your new book
is there a crisis of talent at the
moment i mean objectively we have more
people on the planet than at any time so
there should be more talent to tap into
there is much more talent to tap into
than ever before
but in most parts of the world we are
screwing it up so we require too much
seniority for too many different jobs
there is too much credentialism our
school feeder systems rely too much on
homework and this discriminates against
rebellious people
and just in general we're too slothful
and bureaucratized when it comes to
choosing talent we have these big
interview processes that process many
thousands of people ask them all the
same questions
they do okay u.s does better than most
of the world but we could be doing so
much better and you see this in the
history of women history of minorities
we can do better for virtually all
classes of people
given the fact that recruitment or
finding talent is in the pursuit of
trying to be effective for the company
you would presume
that companies if they were following
practices that optimize for the wrong
parameters
would manage to self-correct that they
would stop doing the thing that isn't
finding the most optimal talent and
actually start doing the thing that is
why is it that organizations are holding
on to a sub-optimal hiring and talent
scouting process
i think the world of venture capital and
startups has more or less operated the
way you're saying that there are truly
significant returns to finding better
talent and for that reason i co-authored
this book with an actual venture
capitalist but so often human resources
departments are not in any direct or
even indirect way residual claimants on
how well the company does their
mentalities are quite conservative they
don't want to rock the boat they don't
want to be blamed for bad hires they
don't often know what to do
with highly creative hires who might
have a rebellious streak in them so like
so much of the contemporary world we
have bureaucratized things far too much
and we try to put forward a less
bureaucratized approach to hiring
rory sutherland says that a lot of hr
departments see hiring as a an
organizational and operational problem
that basically they're looking to
optimize as easily as possible with a
set of parameters because i suppose what
you're saying there is that
looking at creativity personality traits
the way that someone's values come out
in the way that they talk charisma
this is a little bit more messy as
opposed to do you have the correct
credentials if this than that
that's correct and you have to ask the
rather impolite question of whether
organizations are putting their best
people into hr and in fact many of them
are and that can be somewhat of a change
from past practices but in many many
cases they're not they're just putting
people who are good enough into their hr
departments
and those those people then just want to
hire other people who are good enough
um yeah i suppose
the value of top performers in a company
is much much more than the value of
average performers for most enterprises
and that's something hr departments are
not very good at grasping because the
value of a top performer and hr
is not that much higher so that's one of
the key things where having the
mentality of an hr person doesn't
necessarily get you that far
that's interesting so you're saying that
there's power laws that allow the people
that are the absolute best within an
organization to be worth 10 times or 100
times perhaps a normal member
that isn't necessarily reflected in hr
and hr recruits as if it were for its
own department not necessarily for other
ones that's correct now this doesn't
hold for each and every sector if the
job is stuffing donuts into boxes i'm
not sure that the person best at that is
10 times better than the average worker
but if you look at what you might
broadly call the ideas economy creative
work for the most part it's true that
the top performers are at least 10 times
better than the average performers
what's the definition of talent that
you've come to settle on them
in our book we conceive of talent of
people with an energetic spark who have
new and creative ideas who somehow want
to change how things are done now that
can be a ceo it can be
a tech innovator but it can be something
as simple as the person who's my
research assistant who does in fact give
me new ideas i run a podcast i have a
sound producer she's great she gives me
ideas so there's creative talent at many
different levels of the economy but
that's what the book is about not
routine labor but creative talent
what is it about someone that's asking
questions or doing things in a different
way
that helps within an organization you're
right there that the routine
labor needs to be able to follow the
processes you don't need everybody to
try and
revolutionize whatever it is that
they've got in front of them but it's
interesting that there is a particular
type of person personality worker for
which this is a real
advantage
i think when you're interviewing those
people you want to get them into normal
conversational mode and out of interview
mode so we all have a set of canned
interview questions that almost every
decent candidate is ready for they have
their canned answers everyone is a bit
bored at how this process proceeds at
the end of it all you're not sure what
you've learned except oh this is another
candidate who read those three interview
books and came more or less prepared
which maybe is fine it puts them over a
certain threshold if you're trying to
find those people who are 5 or 10x
better
and you simply ask everyone well what
was the mistake you made on your last
job right everyone's ready for that
question by now
so you just want to engage with people
about topics they are passionate in
and see what is their level of detail
what is their level of enthusiasm
do they
impress you with their energy and with
their ability to understand cooperative
teams in a broad variety of settings
just by talking about them
that's what interviews should be doing
rather than just mechanics
how should you set up at the beginning
of a good interview how should you
conduct the the interview itself
well i think you simply have to be
genuine so you want them to trust you
and the best way for them to trust you
is for you to be trustworthy so maybe
share something about yourself but don't
have it be phony don't have it be canned
just talk to them as you would talk to
an actual human being i know that sounds
somewhat radical
uh
but very often that is in fact the best
way to proceed
i was around a friend who has been on a
bunch of movies and a bunch of tv shows
the other night and he was one of the
guys was asking him how are you so good
at playing these different sorts of
roles and
being an actor in various different
scenes and he said well
the advice is always that he's been
given if you need to walk into a room
pick up a glass and drink it you don't
act like you walk into a room pick up an
ass a glass and drink it you just do the
thing it's like
trying to play that second order like
meta role of i'm an interviewer this is
me in interview mode i must ask the
questions like an interviewer asks
you're right it does begin to already
pull you away from whoever the talent is
that's actually in front of you
i want the person to be talking about
something i'm interested in because they
will sense that i am genuinely
interested and that will make them
better and that in turn makes me better
so one thing you can do as an
interviewer is just develop your own
personality and intellect so that you
can be interested in a lot of different
things that the people you're talking to
might care about
what are some good interview questions
that you can ask that might not be uh
typical in an interview process
it will depend on the job of course but
one i like to ask is simply what are the
open tabs on your browser right now
and then get the person talking about
them so something's too personal they
don't have to bring it up that's fine
you're not asking about their personal
lives but let's say they're a lord of
the rings fanatic and they say oh you
know the wikipedia page to something in
lord of the rings is open we'll engage
them on that see what you can learn from
them see how they handle that
uh get a sense of how they organize
information of how they make decisions
of what to follow or not to follow do
they have two thousand open browser tabs
do they have three whatever just
you're getting them talking about how
they manage some part of their ideas
consumption and very likely that's going
to prove useful
it would be a difficult one for me
because i'm a clean freak when it comes
to my desktop so everything would be
shut down it would have been organized
into pocket or a read later app or
something like that i'm not sure that my
answer would be too satisfactory well
that is itself a revealing answer but i
could also ask you what have they been
over the course of the last week
but that says you are extremely well
organized in some way right compensating
for all of the other ways that i'm
terribly unorganized in i think didn't
you have one about conspiracy theories
as well
uh daniel gross and i have this view
that if someone is
creative and wondering and innovative
they should be a bit intrigued by
conspiracy theories now i tend to think
that not that many conspiracy theories
are true but but some of them are true
and haven't you ever wondered like gee
why did jack ruby shoot lee harvey
oswald isn't there something funny there
so again it will depend on the kind of
job if this is a cashier at starbucks
it's probably a misguided line of
questioning
but if you're
looking for someone who will themselves
be asking questions in the course of a
job
uh to see what they think about
different conspiracy theories how do
they analyze them which ones do they
think are plausible what are their
presuppositions
what about you what are conspiracy
theories that have captured you over the
last couple of years
i think a lot of sports betting
conspiracy theories like you know games
are thrown crookedly maybe referees
rather than players they're more true
than is commonly recognized uh that
maybe reflects
a view of mine of human nature that
there's a bit more corruption in
institutions than we recognize
i do think someone put jack ruby up to
killing lee harvey oswald and i no
longer think he was alone assassin and
most of my life i did like i said i
don't believe in many conspiracy
theories but i've seen enough weirdness
in the world over the last five or six
years that now i believe in them a bit
more and i also think while they're
probably not space aliens the pentagon
isn't quite telling us everything it
knows about ufos those would be a few
examples i would agree the last few
years has done uh very little for
dampening down my conspiratorial nature
i don't know how anybody's really come
out of the last
five years or so without a
uh increase in cynicism or skepticism
for the mainstream narrative that we're
told about a lot of things
there's another question i very much
like to ask though it's mainly useful
for people who will run or found
organizations and that's the simple
question how ambitious are you
it's actually very hard to fake and a
lot of people simply aren't that
ambitious which might be fine
but then you should know that going into
funding them so if someone wants to
start a non-profit
i'll almost always ask them how
ambitious are you
and just see if they have a detailed
answer and often the best answer is
people won't even realize how ambitious
they are but they'll be so enthused
about the thing they want to do you get
the sense they're quite ambitious and
then there are people who say oh i'm so
ambitious
but the whole answer is a big empty sack
so that's another favorite question
again at least for founders or leaders
it's interesting thinking about ambition
being uh british where perennial
perennially uh
downplaying our ambition i think that's
just
part of the way that i've noticed the
difference between myself and
people since i've been in america
and i think that reflects a defect in
actually british startup culture
that you have so many assets you have
london you have oxford you have
cambridge and you're becoming
significant in the startup space but
relative to those assets it has been a
slow process and culturally somewhere
like austin where you live to me seems
better
for starting things actually than a lot
of england
i'm finding myself
being
uh pulled along
being uh sped up by the communities that
are around me now but i think i've got
this theory that um
in the uk tall puppy syndrome is a huge
deal right that yes standing out from
the crowd especially when you're younger
is
very uh non-rewarded going through
school if you do things differently if
you deviate i didn't have the accent of
the town the northern working-class town
that i'm from in the uk and that was
something that was pointed out
throughout all of school and um by my
mum slapping me on the back of the hand
when i didn't pronounce my tease or
didn't do whatever when i came back from
school i didn't veer off into that
the difference is that when you grow up
in the uk you have a
i wouldn't even say realistic it's
probably a sub-realistic view of what
you can achieve and where you should go
now the reverse i think seems to happen
in america
for all that america could be accused of
being the worst country in the world
with its patriarchy and
oppression and so on
there's still a american dream blue sky
vision helicopter thinking that gets
given to
young kids there's a lot of people that
are starting businesses here now the
advantage of that is that you believe
you can do anything you want the
disadvantage of that is that when these
kids grow up and the world doesn't
deliver to them the life that they
perhaps expected i think a lot of the
time that delta between the two is what
causes a lot of pain and and perhaps
sometimes claims of corruption uh where
they might not be quite so valid
i very much agree with that i think also
england has so many other dimensions of
status competition you need to worry
about
well what prep school did you go to what
is your accent did your family own land
how do you fit into a variety of
different historical pictures you know
or is your background one of descent or
catholicism
so you have all these opportunities to
achieve status culturally which mean you
are a better cultured country than we
are
and many of you speak much better than
we do or build better art collections or
do other things there are big advantages
to this
but at the same time the fact that we
more or less all go to mcdonald's
means we're keener to achieve status by
say earning a lot of money or starting a
new company well that's the thing when
you've got a more established history
there's just more ways to do stuff
there's a richer set of routes that you
can dig your hands into and go okay well
maybe i could go this way maybe i could
go that way in the uk whereas in america
i mean we've got trees in our country
that are older than your entire country
so given that you think well
of course people are going to be trying
to find that pioneer spirit i i
definitely think it's still here and i
really like it i look i've got this
great story right so i came out to
austin in november and i got invited on
this really huge podcast tim paul's show
and it was the day of the kyle written
house trial verdict oh yeah so i'm
thinking
okay this is going to be quite big only
three days before rogan and alex jones
and a bunch of other people have been in
the same rv where i was in the time it
took me to leave that door there of the
airbnb that i'm back in uh to get
downstairs to get picked up by the
driver
i had two phone calls from people that
i'd only met with in the space of that
one week hey man just wanted to let you
know that i know that you'll probably be
a little bit nervous for tonight but
you're going to crush it i'm going to be
watching the mrs is going to be watching
it's going to be dope i was like oh man
thank you yeah yeah i appreciate it put
the phone down as i put the phone down
another friend who doesn't know that
first one rang and basically said the
same thing
i was like this is so nice it's one of
my favorite memories since i've been
here that within the space of a week
people understood something that meant a
lot to me it they understood the
opportunity they understood how it
mapped into my sort of broader journey
and what i wanted to do and they were
then there to ring me and support me
that would have never ever happened in
the uk
that's great but i would say i'm
optimistic about startups at least in
southern england
i think people from europe
or sometimes south asia who want to do
things they will be naturally drawn to
the london area
well the other thing that you have is
if you've got somebody who has come up
through that tall poppy syndrome
mentality in the uk and still managed to
make it to
perhaps within your uh
vision on your radar of founders
startups
you know that they've probably had to
dredge through a fair bit of
cultural pushback
in order to get there so that's probably
a
another node of information that is
informative at least that's right and it
could be a lot of your best founders
won't be british at all
but if you think there has to be some
kind of startup capital in european time
zones it's hard to see where else it
would be when you go through all the
other alternatives
like amsterdam is too small germany is
too for clumped you know
power
bureaucratic oh sort of
a little bit grumpy and crouched up and
not you know entirely explosive and
innovative
procedural
yes
yeah okay and again germany has its own
strengths it's a wonderful country but
it's not going to be the startup capital
of europe
have you seen how much portugal has been
pushing to get people to go at the
moment
i was just in portugal i think for the
fourth time i had a wonderful experience
but i think ultimately they will become
the retirement capital of europe
which i mean in a very positive way
because a lot of retirees are going to
do some fairly significant things but
even with their very favorable tax
treatment on crypto and other areas
capital gains i don't think it's big
enough or culturally central enough to
be a startup capital
uh but i am bullish on the country they
do many things very well and there's
some of the world's least craziest
people and i mean that in a good way but
it's not entirely a good thing for being
a startup capital you want to have some
of the world's craziest people along a
particular dimension
didn't they do have they legalized
certain drugs
they're decriminalized many drugs and
that has gone well it seems to be doing
better for them than say u.s drug policy
they're not legal for the most part uh
but you don't get thrown in jail and
they've had modest improvements and
outcomes
it was the first time ever that i got
targeted with ads from a country
uh to move there they were doing this
big push for
nomadic internet entrepreneurs and
crypto people
come and live in lisbon or pharaoh it's
on gmt so it's the same time zone as
london and we'll give you these tax
benefits and this is how much it's going
to cost to live here and the weather's
like this
fair play
for amenities culture weather
cuisine
proximity to europe time zone it's
perfect
but population is small and just
creative spark and people who live there
it's not a big enough country i guess is
my fear but it's a great place i plan on
going back porto is a true gem also
going back to talent
what have you come to believe about the
innateness of talent
well there's a lot of
evidence from the sciences that many
features are you know 50 percent or a
bit more genetic
but talent is everywhere so i don't
think you should obsess over thinking
about a person's parents you know my
father didn't go to college the people
whose parents did very well are already
most likely to be spotted you're trying
to look for people that the system is
missing
so one thing the book argues is don't
obsess over genetics
think about the real live interactions
before you
i like to see people try to write out an
idea to evaluate how they think so i'm a
big believer in companies institutions
that have writing cultures
and
engage them in the moment and there's
places such as south asia most of all
india that 30 40 years ago were really
not seen as talent hot spots at all
and today india has a phenomenal record
in tech and with tech ceos but in
virtually every area
so the value of the english language has
gone up you do want to look at countries
and regions where there's good internet
access and that's way more important
than like some notion of genetics
the classic idiom of uh
hard work beats talent when talent
doesn't work hard what have you seen
about the relationship between talent
and hard work
well i think when it comes to
intelligence a lot of smart people in
particular they overvalue smarts and
others and they think they're so so so
smart
there's a lot of evidence in researching
the book i was surprised how strong the
evidence is
that smarts are not that closely
correlated with income that for a lot of
jobs you probably have to be at some
certain level of smarts to do the job at
all but above that level it's very hard
to find big correlations between
intelligence or iq and outcomes
so energy ability to work well with
others
ambition
just the ability to stick with something
durability
what i call the ability to see the right
hierarchies in an organization and know
which are the right ones to climb that's
something i definitely look for in
people there's so many talented people
and they just spend their time playing
games
literally playing games and they don't
do anything
and they're energetic they work hard at
playing games or they play chess
whatever
and they don't go anywhere because
they're maximizing along the wrong
hierarchies
how should somebody that is playing a
game step back and see the broader
picture what is it that they're missing
it's very easy to optimize too locally
and we all do this in different ways you
have a peer group
and you in some way appeal to that peer
group but the peer group might be people
you grew up with or they could be other
gamers i grew up you know as a
10 year old 11 12 year old playing chess
in new york city my friends were all
chess players uh
a lot of them are still playing
but it's not a great life
and i think just to always be looking
around and trying to see one level more
one level high or one level broader and
this is one of the things you want to
get at in interviews can people see
things other than what is before
their eyes at the moment and i like to
ask them about books or plays or movies
or tv shows whatever they want to talk
about
and just see can they see beyond the
immediate moment if they talk about
shakespeare the sopranos star wars
whatever their thing is jane austen
just see how much further they can go
with it
didn't you suggest or ask them to um put
another act onto the end of a book or uh
see what would happen in romeo and
juliet if something had changed
those are good questions if that's what
they know about there's going to be
something they know about right you
don't have to be an expert in it but you
have to know enough that their answer is
at least intelligible to you so just ask
them about that
if they're a shakespeare fan ask them
are romeo and juliet really in love with
each other
let's see what they say see if they've
even thought about that
it's strange for me to think about the
correlation between iq
and school grades and resumes and cvs
and wrote uh education
is it
is it a little bit of a difficult
situation for somebody that's growing up
now who is having to go through this
almost a charade i guess unless they've
got a ton of bravery to then decide to
step outside of the school system
because they're going to think i want to
be a founder in this thing
if i decide to go complete college
dropout that's probably a little bit of
a high risk strategy i've got all of
this pressure from parents i've got all
of this pressure from institutions
telling me that this is what i'm
supposed to do
that selects for a particular type of
rebelliousness that someone who's a
little bit more orderly but perhaps just
as talented who might stick in
university might not be the same i'm
trying to sort of dissect apart all of
these different people
i think it's criminal what we're doing
so i'm advising some young people right
now who are applying to stanford mit
berkeley
and they tell me and these these people
are not whiners or complainers they say
it takes a full six months of their life
just to do the applications the essays
the paperwork get everything lined up
i think the process if anything should
be more random now if we could perfect
and fine-tune it fine but compared to
what we're doing now which is the
selecting for a certain kind of i
wouldn't call it mindless effort but a
kind of obedient effort
i would rather just look at people above
some level and then randomize that i
would prefer to what we're doing now
where rewarding homework at every stage
of the process and then we're shocked
when we get too many conformists
what do you mean by randomize
it would be perfectly acceptable if a
school such as harvard said you needed
to have you know scores or grades or
something above a certain level or some
basic level of extracurricular
activities
they would take like 5x the pool they
end up choosing and within that 5x pool
literally randomize you know draw names
out of a hat i think it would be better
why
because they are looking for particular
models
which are what their you know admissions
counselors think are fine upstanding
americans and that to me is just a
little scary
and it does emphasize homework too much
and having jumped through hoops at
various levels and i think they should
admit you know more people who are
somewhat more like john lennon or pablo
picasso
i'm in austin at the moment and there's
a lot of waldorf schools here yeah and
tim kennedy that i was with this week is
the headmaster
i don't even know what it's what the
type of school is it's even more
non-typical than a waldorf school where
um the students get to determine their
own
uh class structures and all sorts of
stuff they basically put tons and tons
of agency on the kids even at five and
six years old um
and i think that that non-typical
education early on you're going to see
more and more of that i think parents
increasingly i went to university i did
two degrees at uni i got a
master's in international marketing and
i learned more in the first six months
of running my business while i was at
university than in the entire five years
that i spent at uni
so
for everybody that does have successful
parents increasingly now outside of
institutions or at least
having come through the institutions but
resented at the academia that they went
through while they were doing it because
they kind of realized in retrospect it
was a little bit pointless
i do think that you're going to see
parents encourage kids to take
non-typical routes the good news in the
us is the last five years we have so
intensified the pace of k-12
experimentation i do not myself pretend
to know what the right answer is but
there are many many many more
experiments some of that brought on by
the pandemic but if you look at higher
education within a given quality tier of
university
schools are just competing to be more
like each other
so the school rated number 32 will try
to be more like mit in some way rather
than just doing its own thing so it's
still massively conformist at the higher
ed level but as you say k through 12
we've made a lot of breakthroughs
there's a lot more homeschooling shorter
schools other models are very bullish
about how this is going to play out
given the fact that
genetics is a big chunk of what we're
talking about even though you've said
it's maybe been overplayed in the past
is there an argument that you should
meet the parents of a super
high importance crucial hire i mean
it is kind of strange to me that a lot
of the time you will meet the parents of
your
girlfriend or boyfriend uh even if you
only end up being with them for a year
or something like that but
meeting the parents of a potential
candidate i don't know might seem a
little bit more strange
well i have a principal when i have
young people apply for my fellowships
which are called emerging ventures
uh i asked one very young applicant i
think he was 15.
how did you hear about us and he said my
mother told me to apply
and that was a no right then and there
why
he was seemed very smart seemed like a
hard worker was in an excellent school
probably he'll do just fine in life
maybe he will excel in life
but i felt he was not self-driven
and the value added from his dealing
with me or getting money from me would
be zero
so the parents who refused to meet with
you would be the ones who would impress
me in that setting
again i'm not my own personal role i'm
not looking for just people who will do
well i'm looking for undervalued talent
that won't do as well if i don't help
them and that is a difference if you
just want people who will do well just
sort of optimizing for parents who have
done well and so on and i mean that's
fine right that's going to work
pick out a rhodes scholar while you're
at it
that's interesting i didn't realize that
that was one of the things you optimized
for but it makes complete sense why
why do you need to assist somebody
that's already probably going to be
successful within the structures that
exist
right there was another phone call i had
it was with someone in rural peru which
is not really a hot spot for that much
of anything
uh
one of his parents
was absent
he seemed super ambitious even at age i
think 16 or 17 spoke excellent english
which he learned mainly through youtube
found out about my program on his own uh
you know may still have some rough
patches but struck me as someone with
real potential who really truly wants to
succeed get out of there go somewhere
else make something of himself
uh that person i'm keener to help
that's really nice that's really nice to
hear that that you know people who don't
have that obvious route to success are
going to be assisted with it there was
um something i saw about
the value of talking about drama
there's a very common uh adage about
great minds discuss ideas average minds
discuss events small minds discuss
people and then i think there's one
about podcasters which is podcasters
discuss people discussing events
but yeah talk to me about drama what can
you learn from asking people to discuss
drama
well i think you want to discuss people
again it depends on the job if someone
is simply programming from a distance it
may not matter but most jobs you're
working with other people but you don't
get very far by tell me about an
instance where you work together well
with someone again you're just testing
for prep
what you want to do is get them talking
about other people spontaneously so i
try to find out something they're
interested in
you know if it's star wars i'll just ask
did yoda give good advice
or who was the best talent scout in star
wars was it obi-wan was it yoda was it
darth vader
i don't really care if i agree with
their answer
i care how they show that they've been
thinking about it
and that's a way of getting them to talk
about people it's not threatening like
yoda doesn't exist right
you know you're not in school
[Laughter]
but at the same time if a person is say
a star wars fan and has never thought
about these questions
you figure they're a bit oblivious again
for many jobs that will be fine for
other jobs it's a danger sign
what was that story about spacex's
hiring strategy
elon musk uh according to the book of ed
spacex was directly personally involved
with the first several thousand of their
hires that he knew for spacex to work
you needed people
who actually thought it was important
that mankind reached mars that you know
thought these rockets would work and
that you could revolutionize space
travel and clearly he succeeded with
that project
there was a conversation i had with the
navy seal rich divini uh about a year
ago and he had this really interesting
insight i wonder if you agree with he
said typically companies hire on skills
and fire on attributes so when you sit
down with somebody you look at their
resume you make sure they've got the
requisite qualifications and whatever
but most of the time when somebody gets
kicked off they're not kicked off
because they don't have they can't
program in c plus or they don't have
whatever the medical
license that they're supposed to have
the issues is that they are unable to
work in a team or they're not
trustworthy or they don't have grit
that to me seemed really interesting
that look at what you're optimizing for
on the front end and look at what the
problem is on the back end those two
things don't seem to match up in
companies that are hiring poorly
strongly agree and that's an interesting
anecdote because i've known a few former
navy seals and uniformly they are super
insightful about talent
so their own process to me
seems quite fascinating i've read a
number of books about it that's no
substitute for having gone through it
but it seems to me an
underutilized source of insight and
expertise is navy seals
uh i would agree having spent a little
bit of time with some in austin they're
um
yeah it's it's interesting thinking
about that because it's not just
whoever's the best shot or whoever can
run the quickest mile it's not
objective
parameters of success in whatever it is
they're trying to do communication
signals fighting whatever it's very much
coordination and being able to keep up
the intangibles and i suppose that
it's so bizarre that we've we've kind of
tried to create
rules mostly arbitrary rules about what
we're trying to look for in a person
when what you're doing is having
conversations about star wars and and
whether what would have happened if
another act in romeo and juliet had been
added on to the end that that seems
more natural in a way but oddly now it's
it's revolutionary because it's so far
away from the typical process
it seems to me that navy sales
understand the importance of practice
and improvement that's something i try
to ask people about
and navy seals understand the importance
of coordinating your different talents
so they're working together in a way
that athletes say top players in the nba
understand
but for a lot of normal jobs we somehow
don't think about closely enough
i've had an idea for a long time david
perrell who i think you're familiar with
as well oh sure great great guy yeah
he's fantastic good friend he had a blog
post called think like an athlete and it
turned out that the blog post had
absolutely nothing to do with what i
interpreted the title as but in classic
style i decided to make my own idea
about the blog post without reading it
and it turned out to be a concept that i
really enjoyed i noticed that
most and he cites me in that i was the
one who put him on to that stuff i said
david you should think more like an
athlete what is it you do every day
that's practiced the way an athlete or
concert pianist might do
i really should have read that blog post
uh anyway it's something that stuck with
me and it turns out that i landed pretty
close to exactly what he was talking
about so few people treat their chosen
pursuit
like athletes do the same level of rigor
around their conditioning their mindset
their recovery their sleep their
nutrition their hydration their
performance their game talk their
strategies their tactics everything
nobody
really seems to take maybe uh top level
um
musicians like classical musicians and
stuff like that perhaps some chess
players and stuff but
the degrees of
separation and the lack of a linear line
from your inputs in terms of your
preparation and your outcomes in terms
of your performance
they're so messy
i have a podcast with you today it's
very difficult for me to work out
whether this podcast is objectively
better or worse than the one that i did
yesterday it's very difficult for me to
work out if i'd gone to bed half an hour
earlier if that would have improved if
i'd had another glass of water earlier
on today if i'd optimized my nutrition
the line is so blurry whereas if it's
power lifting
300 kilos on a barbell is always 300
kilos you have a very objective measure
of your performance as you go up as you
peak so on and so forth and
increasingly to me i find that like that
was one of the most romantic ideas that
i've heard ever since i read that and
then spoke to david about it it was one
of the most romantic ideas that i that i
heard because i thought well i really
like the idea of committing myself to
one thing as hard as i can to see just
how good i can become at that and that
was what inspired me to start working
with addiction coach for the podcast so
i worked with addiction coach to improve
my pronunciation and work on some speech
defects that i had and then he worked on
my delivery and then i started to work
with a comedy coach because i wanted to
work on my humor so that my timing could
be better i thought this is great but
it's rare
i go see a lot of stand-up comedy in
part for this reason but i once
interviewed economist larry summers and
i went back i looked through a lot of
his work a lot of larry on youtube and
he struck me as one of the few
economists who over time his answers to
the same questions get better not a
question of agreeing with him or not but
he just expresses it better or he
changes his mind
and he explained in my interview with
him that he consciously sets out to
think through his answers which ones
were not so good how can i improve them
for the next time and for weeks months
maybe years he'll be thinking about how
can i make this answer better it sounds
so trivial
but the percentage of even top
economists who do that i promise you is
quite small
it's the same for everyone i find this
on the show that especially if you've
listened to somebody speak
for a good while beforehand in
preparation
as you ask a question you can begin to
see if this person's going to tumble
into the same canned answer that they
typically give or if they're going to
honestly assess what they think about
that question right now and i see i see
this in myself as well right it's very
easy to give the answer to common
questions that people always ask you
because it's easier it's it's the path
of least resistance whereas if you go
okay well
what do i think about that question
with me right now with my feet stood
here in this time and space that's right
and navy seals seem to get this as a
general mentality not that they spend
their time answering questions but they
do other things
and uh
very top chess players concert pianists
some athletes navy seals they're some of
the people i've tried to learn from
stand-up comics what's interesting about
them i've met a number of them they're
not funny
when you spend actual regular time with
them
when they are funny on stage it's an
extreme devotion of prac to practice
most of them are not intrinsically that
funny
and that was a revelation when i saw
that
that's interesting because that's not my
experience with the ones that i've spent
time with now that just might be my
selection bias or yours but the ones the
ones that i spend time with they don't
seem to be able to switch it off
i go out for dinner with them and
they're just
i constantly whether they're playing a
little bit of the entertainment role
just purely for my benefit i don't know
but um
yeah that's not that's not my experience
you know one of them who's very well
known said to me he won't take material
on television until he's tried it out
with live audiences maybe 40 times and
modified it and proved it this would be
one of the very best known stand-up
comics
at 40 times is a lot if they say it's
well five times eight times okay
but 40 times from someone at the top of
his profession that to me was really
striking
i've seen uh rogan perform twice uh in
austin and the way that they do it is
they make you put your phone into one of
those special sacks you may have been to
a show like this before and it locks and
you gotta give it to them at the end of
the night uh no recording allowed no
heckling from the crowd allowed and his
set um
from the first time that i saw him in
november to the second time that i saw
him in
mid-april uh was structurally very very
similar uh but in terms of delivery was
was quite different and you think well
it's like it's the same story it's the
same joke but
just iterating night after night what
works what doesn't it is it's like the
split testing for life i suppose
yeah rogan in particular has perfected
something i'm not sure how to describe
it but people who think that rogan or
some other top performers just randomly
got to the places they're at you know mr
beast or pewdiepie no
you may or may not like what they do but
they have perfected something through
extreme practice and diligence and
trying to figure out what works and what
doesn't
the thing is with those guys they're the
common denominator amongst all of their
successes and this is why
no matter what people think about him
logan paul as far as i'm concerned is a
media master that guy has nailed every
single thing that he decided now he's
been involved in some nft projects that
are a bit dodgy
but apart from those ones
his ability to deploy
his personality and to understand how
he's positioned to understand how people
see him does this did you ever see when
he got invited on
is is msnbc is that the business channel
in america yes but but i need to watch
him i don't know about him at all where
should i start oh god uh just have a
look on youtube and see what the
algorithm serves you okay a few short
clips that would be interesting have a
look as well at the msnbc interview that
he did it was around about two years ago
so logan paul goes on to msnbc
it must be when tax returns have just
been released or something uh so his net
worth had been made public somehow i
don't know how that works in america and
they were asking him about his business
and about his strategies and he had this
it was called the challenger games which
was like
influencers and youtubers doing sporting
events against each other and that was
his next big thing and it was maybe a
week or a couple of weeks away and he
was competing in it but also running it
and um this lady's having a conversation
with him and she's trying to desperately
trying to drag the conversation back to
business he immediately starts talking
about the fact that he's got pink eye
because he's pretty sure that one of his
housemates rubbed his arse on his pillow
then he's saying that he's pretty sure
he's the fastest man on the planet he
can't wait to prove to the world that
he's the fastest man on the planet and
he's doing it in like a really charming
really funny way and the lady that's
trying to have this conversation with
him is trying to hold it together
struggling it's really funny and then
sure enough the internet lights up logan
paul starts trending on twitter saying
uh this guy's a complete idiot he's been
invited on to talk about finances he
doesn't have a clue and then about a
week later he tweeted the change in his
google search volume and the revenue
that he made from his youtube channel
from all of the people that had searched
for him bought his stuff and watched his
videos and he was like who's the idiot
now
i always love discovering new people
like this so i will check him out he's a
serious guy uh going back to the talent
thing it seems to me that there's two we
never left the talent thing to be clear
but go on
going directly back to it there's it
seems like there's two two elements here
um first you need to be able to source
talent and then you need to be able to
assess talent
yes what about the sourcing sourcing is
often the most important problem so if
you think of yourself as some kind of
genius sitting in a chair pointing at
people and making choices
it's a very limited understanding of how
talent search works i think most
institutions that don't put enough time
into developing their soft network
of who are their contacts
and who is looking for them
so the way they do well a talent is to
have talented people looking for you
right not you looking for talented
people there's many more of them than
there are of you
so there's a whole chapter of the book
on how to use scouts to find more
talented people but also how do you
encourage talented people to be looking
for you and in so many sectors that is
you know 80 or 90 of the problem not you
sitting in a chair and pointing you are
talented come we hire you
yes that's part of it but uh who shows
up at your door and why
thinking about how scalable it is for
people to want to come and work for you
versus you having to pick people off
with a sniper rifle right it's like do
you want to be the magnet that's
attracting all of the different iron
filings together or do you want to be
able to see do you want to have to pick
them apart individually one by one by
one
what are some of the ways that you can
become more magnetic with regards to
trying to get people to like the idea of
coming to you
again it depends on your sector but to
have some kind of public presence where
you are in some way impressive it's
going to attract people
so
peter thiel is one of the people who has
been best at this peter does a lot on
youtube other public venues i know many
people strongly disagree with peter's
views but that's not my point here
peter radiates something when he speaks
and some intensity and seriousness of
purpose and it's also not too accessible
i think that's key to peter's appeal
it's not too simple to make sense out of
there's its own terminology its own
world view
uh maybe even ideas in there that a lot
of people are just turned off by so you
have to get through a lot of filters to
get peter and then the people who come
up to peter you know after his talks
after his youtube recordings
that's a great source of contacts for
peter and he's one of the masters
of kind of sending out the bat signal in
just the right way so he's a good person
to learn that from
uh someone who's a i think a tremendous
ceo a great talent but he's not a bat
signal kind of person would be mark
zuckerberg
uh who has done a great job with you
know now meta formerly facebook
hiring other talented people but mark is
not out there in the same way so that
would be a contrast
i moderated the discussion with peter
thiel at palmer lucky's house about
three weeks ago for alex epstein's new
book and um i was struck
by what you mean it's not it's not leet
speak in a lingo but it is kind of a
part of a particular type of thinking a
mode of thinking that some people are
going to get and some people aren't and
what's interesting about
the suggestion that you're making there
is that
by it requiring a little bit of work for
people to get to to understand
it creates a sense
not group dynamics of like in group out
group but like i am a part of a movement
because we have a particular type of
world view that is represented in the
language and that the work that it takes
to get yourself there to be able to
understand the concepts that peter's
talking about
it
suggests prestige it suggests
aspiration uh and and gravitas
and what peter can do is take a topic
and show you there's some angle
that he has thought more deeply about
than you have
and most people don't see that because
they haven't thought deeply about it
enough themselves but the people who do
see oh peter has this different
perspective that whether or not i agree
with it is deeper than mine
you're selecting for people of some
depth and determination and peter yes he
is articulate and quick but they're not
the dimensions he specializes in there
are people more articulate or quicker
than peter but this new perspective this
more intense layer of depth he might be
number one and that's the bat signal you
have to pick up
and it's hard
i think it's hard on purpose
i think that you're right as well he had
this great insight
um about we're talking about uh
environmental catastrophe and climate
change he said that the people who are
extreme optimists and extreme pessimists
horseshoe around to cash out at the
exact same position
that the people who believe that we're
going to be able to fix everything and
the people that we believe that we can't
do anything about it cash out at the
exact same position and that's not
difficult to get that's completely
obvious and it's staring you in the face
and as he was saying it i'm thinking to
myself
oh my god how have i never i've thought
about this for a long time read both of
alex's books how have i never considered
the fact that both of those people at
the extremes they're not far apart from
each other they've actually looped back
around and they're basically in the same
position that is peter exactly very good
example
he understands that
the dialectic in a way that is unusual
well he's partly not american of course
he was born in germany maybe that's
appropriate
but he understands dialectical thinking
better than
maybe anyone else i know
what about convincing people to join
your cause or to buy into the movements
that you're doing we've spoken about how
peter can kind of attract talent but
it's not just attracting them it's
getting them to believe and getting them
to buy in and getting them to want to be
motivated to come and do the stuff for
you they have this talent they've got
the characteristics and the traits and
the attributes that we're looking for
but then they need something
more to get them to be to uh deploy that
in the direction that you want them to
you need to offer people an attractive
small group of immediate peers or maybe
sometimes not so small group the big
winner in recent times on doing this is
the effective altruism movement and
again put aside whether you agree or
disagree they are right now attracting
so much talent the rest of the world
doesn't even realize it that the
percentage of say
top teenage talent i speak to who are
interested in effective altruism it is
off the charts so they are winning on
that dimension and there's the sense now
that if you in some way join effective
altruism as a movement those are your
peers and they are your peers they've
done phenomenally well you know kudos to
them
it's an interesting one i've been
thinking throughout this conversation
trying to
draw a parallel between what i do which
is this show this is the
primary project i'm working on at the
moment and i think that the the talent
that i'm mostly looking to attract now
is
guests
i think that i'm trying to find people
who have interesting things to say who
understand what i'm trying to achieve on
the show and who want to come and tell
the audience something that they don't
already know in a new interesting
innovative way and i was trying to think
about soft networks and getting people
to join the cause and stuff like that
and
i would say that there's certainly some
of the dynamics that we talked about
today that map onto that
where i've gone and spoken to dwarkash
is a great example one of your uh
padawans and a a mutual friend of ours
and um
he every time that we sit down we're
constantly bouncing ideas off each other
oh i gotta introduce you to this guy oh
i gotta introduce you to this guy i went
for pizza with him on tuesday and i
mentioned that you were coming on the
show and i got home and i had
three different youtube videos in my
imessage he's like you've got to watch
this you've got to watch this you've got
to watch this none of them were his he's
not showing me his own content he's
thinking hard and deep about that
very very nice when you've got something
that is a movement that people care
about they understand what you're doing
and then they start to do stuff on your
behalf that helps you get to the place
that they know that you want to get to
and those could well be the people you
spend the rest of your life working with
in some way not all of them maybe just
two three percent of them but they
become your collaborators
is there a difficulty in seeing
talent in people when they can't see it
in themselves
well i mean there's it's always a
difficult thing to spot talent right
but if you get a person talking there
are plenty of people who don't have
enough confidence
but are quite significant as talents and
i find this especially frequently in
women
for whatever sociological reason there's
a confidence gap between men and women
there are plenty of men who have way too
much confidence and a large number of
very smart women who don't have enough
confidence
so the confidence problem
in part becomes a gender issue
and
especially in the world of podcasting
but you can be a super successful and
super talented man and still be quite
poor at spotting talent in women and
that's really something a lot of people
ought to work on more and daniel and i
have a whole chapter on that in the book
i learned about the daughter effect last
week have you heard about this of course
and i have a daughter i agree with the
daughter effect if you don't have a
daughter it sounds a lot less plausible
but i agree that if you have a daughter
there are things about women you
understand that you have not learned
from you know wife girlfriends whatever
sister
it's really quite striking
it's funny it is interesting and i think
is it five percent that the people who
work underneath somebody that a boss
that has a daughter get paid on average
females get paid on average five percent
to 10 more i don't remember the number
but there is a noticeable effect
that's an interesting one everybody
should be uh mandated a daughter by the
government everybody that's in a
position of power that would fix that
problem
i now have a granddaughter so this is
uh 15 to 20 now is that the way it works
well i wonder if there's a granddaughter
effect right uh
i i've never seen a paper on that
talking about confidence and charisma
and stuff like that
a lot of the time charisma can fill in a
lot of cracks where maybe talent or hard
work
um doesn't
what how important is charisma and then
how can you avoid
um being seduced
by charisma so that you look past some
of the things that people perhaps are
lacking with
for many leadership positions charisma
is highly significant to get other
people to work for you and to care
uh most positions are not leadership
positions so
don't be fooled by charisma when you
don't need charisma
but if someone say wants to start a
non-profit
which almost always is underpaying its
workers right by the nature of the
nonprofit sector they had better have
some decent charisma or their chance of
succeeding is not that great so it's
going to be highly sector specific
but if it's about a product if it's like
a furniture factory in cincinnati ohio
charisma still matters but it's an
entirely different story
i heard you daniel have a discussion
about the difference between
obsessiveness and competitiveness what's
that
well my take on the matter and i'm not
sure if daniel agrees but he is more
competitive than i am but i am more
obsessive than he is so a lot of my work
as a writer public intellectual academic
has been fairly solo
i think i'm pretty unusual that i don't
compare myself against peers that often
like there's no person out there where i
know how many twitter followers they
have
and i do a lot of things that i don't
measure but just keep on doing them for
years decades
and that's a form of obsessiveness
competitiveness is you're in a sector
and there are actual identifiable
companies you're competing against and
you have to beat them
that's
never been what most of my projects are
like some of them have a tinge of that
but mostly they're about obsessiveness
over the decades
do you think they cash out in a similar
way
when you say cash out what do you mean
the way that they manifest in
performance somebody that is competitive
and somebody that is obsessive do you
think that they end up performing in a
similar sort of way oh no very different
ways so if you're looking for projects
that will make money you're probably
better off with the competitive person
if you're looking for projects based
around ideas that will have impact and
may or may not make money you might do
better with the obsessive person
just to give an example um
yeah it's
i would say i would probably put myself
in the obsessive rather than the
competitive category um
i wonder whether that's a function of
being an only child uh and working in uh
solitude for forever i suppose it
probably is yeah yeah i think that's
probably a byproduct of it
how
how easy do you think it is to fix
somebody with bad values let's say that
you find someone who is an unbelievable
talent that has ticks all of the boxes
except for
they they really really struggle at
working in a team or they're a little
bit toxic as a personality or something
like that
how
how fixable is that or are those sort of
malignancies that you just can't get
past it's usually not fixable they're
very very few cases i've seen where that
works
with some people simply getting married
or having children or aging helps quite
a bit but your ability to fix it i would
say treat that as close to zero
i saw a study a long time ago about
what happens when you introduce one bad
apple into a group you may have seen
this
and basically they were asking
does the person
rise does the performance of the
underperformer rise up to the level of
the high performing group or does it
drag the performance of the group down
and it seemed pretty reliably to be that
the entire group's performance gets
damaged by just one person because that
person is dragging their feet everybody
else feels resentful of them everybody
starts down regulating their work output
to match that person then there's
infighting amongst everybody because
they know that they're not doing as well
and it all stems from one person in a
small group
we say in the book just never hire toxic
people not if they have to work with
others
tyler cowan ladies and gentlemen uh if
people want to keep up to date with what
you do where should they go
on twitter i'm at tyler cowan my new
book co-authored with daniel gross is
called talent i write a blog at marginal
revolution and i have my own podcast
conversations with tyler chris it's been
a real pleasure i hope we get to meet
someday me too i appreciate you thanks
tyler take care what's happening people
thank you very much for tuning in if you
enjoyed that episode then press here for
a selection of the best clips from the
podcast over the last few weeks and
don't forget to subscribe
peace